grantham in the Lincolnshire flatlands a
railway town of no-nonsense East
Midlands redbrick the birthplace of the
Conservative Party's most famous
daughter Margaret Thatcher if the
current Prime Minister is to get middle
England behind her brexit deal she needs
to win over places like Grantham Theresa
May is trying to change the public
perception of her deal
she knows the only way that wavering and
peace might vote for it as if they feel
their constituents breathing down their
necks but that won't be easy the sky
data poll suggests just 12 percent of
people feel the deal delivers on what
people voted for I think it's been a
disaster I really do and it's a shame
because I personally I voted for Brett
to say it's not perfect with everyone is
it but she sits the best on the table if
you don't go for that we get a no deal
and what's gonna be worse no deal isn't
it what would you like to see happen no
in an ideal world if I could wave a
magic wand brexit leap ahead
I'm just thoroughly bored with it you're
bored of Breck's that absolutely bored
indeed the local Conservative MP Nick
Bowles says he will vote for the Prime
Minister's brexit deal but he's
brokering an alternative plan if it
falls known as Norway plus I think the
most important thing about my plan B is
that it's nobody's plan a and this is
not a perfect deal that I'm proposing
but it is one that is doable and it's
because they all see that at the moment
we might be heading off the cliff we're
going to do with Thelma Louise and drive
straight off the cliff into the sunset
and that's not something that almost
anyone really wants to see and they do
see the potential of the Norway option
to get us out of the EU and avoid no
deal so how many members of the cabinet
you talk about it well I've spoken to
probably now six or eight members of the
cabinet I don't want to say that they're
all completely signed up to this as a
plan-b I mean of course they're all
supporting the Prime Minister's plan
first and foremost do you agree with
your colleagues who say that after
brexit is they hope done next year it's
time for Theresa May to hand over to a
new generation of conservatives I think
we're definitely going to need to have
fresh faces new ideas
and new leadership before the next
election I think it should be up to
tourism a to decide precisely when she
wants to hand over my own view would be
it can't be just before the next
direction there needs to be a decent
period for someone to be able to
demonstrate what their new approach and
their new ideas would deliver for the
British people so I hope that she would
see mission completed on the 29th of
March as the time to start thinking
about when it is that she wants to hand
over to a successor the Prime Minister
insists the choices between her deal no
deal or no brexit but if she can't get
it through the House of Commons she'll
need a plan B
Sophie register news Grantham